don't ask me I'm not talking about the
view at all I'd do it all day long
Whoopi Goldberg is opening up about her
time on the view and it's not what you'd
expect this is my job that's what they
pay me did to do and so before y'all
start tweeting and semi all that stuff I
don't care what you think this is my job
her job of over ten years to be exact
the oscar-winning actress recently sat
down with the New York Times and spoke
candidly about her role on the morning
talk show when The Times asked Goldberg
if the show addresses her creative
impulses she simply replied no and as
for if she gets creative fulfillment
from the view the 63 year old just said
it's my job yes I did say it I did say
it the comedian did tell the times that
she's doing in form of acting on the
show quote in a way I am playing a role
these are not conversations that I'm
having with my friends if they were we'd
be doing it differently my friends and I
can talk about things in depth in a
different way than you can on television
doesn't matter how good you are and she
added what you're asking is is the view
enough it's not you know I'm so trying
to do what I want to do and do it well
The Morning Show star did reveal she's
been pursuing a passion of hers THC
products I think it's important for
people to know how good cannabis can
work for lots of different things and
and in children in particular because I
would rather offer a child this way to
heal themselves as opposed to taking the
pills and she's even in the business of
making clothes yeah now you know making
clothes and shirts and stuff just slow
you know if you don't marry well oh no
no no you got to keep working this is no
joke if you're not marrying a
millionaire yo ass gonna be working
[Music]